[Music]
hold still gives a snapshot of life
during lockdown
there are so many memories of what
lockdown meant
moments that the duchess of cambridge
wanted all of us
to share in the end these were the
pictures chosen by kate and a panel of
judges to best sum up what the country
has been through
now forming a digital exhibition on the
national portrait gallery website
lemsi say was one of the judges and said
at times they had to take
breaks from looking at the photos
because it was such an emotional process
when historians look back at this time
this exhibition will show them how
the nation feels open
honest sharing strong
heroic right in the middle of this storm
of a pandemic that we're in at the
moment
um yeah making made me proud
launched in may they received over 30
000
photos in six weeks covering three
themes
helpers and heroes your new normal and
acts of kindness
the queen described the images as
inspiring after being shown
six of them by kate including this one
of amelia houston
her mum wendy told me it's meant the
world her family
and the rest of the down's syndrome
community it's international dancer's
day so i just
definitely wanted to do a post because
of what was going on with the pandemic
also because amelia's seen a lot of
nurses in her short life
and also she has two uh very close
family members who are both nurses and
were working through the pandemics so it
was something i really
wanted to put out there and say thank
you
the queen's support is a significant pat
on the back for the duchess
and her project but also recognizes
its lasting impact forever a reminder
of the pain the humor and the resilience
shown in these unsettling times rhiannon
mills
sky news